so your first two films easier with
practice than Co GB are adapted works
for any producers or filmmakers out
there or interested in optioning and
adapting an author's work how how do we
go about it what are some of the first
steps the first steps is usually if you
go to the author's site you can find
agent information or contact so this is
assuming if you're totally independent
you don't have an agent you don't have
manager no one that can sort of inquire
these things for you usually you want to
look and see who their reps are usually
you can find that online like that's
usually pretty easy and if they have a
Los Angeles like a talent then you
probably want to call them first because
they're gonna be people are gonna want
to talk to about film rights find out
where the rights are first and foremost
you know and then from there what it
really first of all you need to get a
lawyer at some point on it like that's
the most important thing cuz I've I
tried to do it without a lawyer once it
was just wrong like it's just where you
just will always want you never want to
sign anything about anything that where
you're putting money into it or there's
some kind of long-term agreement without
a lawyer you're looking at over like you
just everyone knows someone who's a
lawyer who can probably you know sue I'm
not saying you have to pay thousands and
thousands for a fancy lawyer but you
definitely don't want to sign an
agreement with a writer that you're
going to put time and money investment
into writing a script and maybe making
into a movie unless someone's approved
this initial agreement first because
those things can come back to haunt you
they never have for me it's always
worked out well but I know and I've
heard stories and it can happen you just
want a lawyer that's the no matter what
you want one um but you know you want to
see how open they are saying yes you
want to see how how much money it's
gonna cost what you know typically I
find that where you want you want to be
able to talk to the author you know you
want to be able to be sincere with your
intention of what you want to do work
and communicate that to them you know so
it's you know for for Davey
Rothbart that the first first movie was
based on he was really interested in
film and this was a magazine article he
wrote but it was part of his life and
getting in touch with him is a little
bit easier but I also went through like
a friend who was at an agency so that I
didn't have any agents but I had a
friend call who was working at an agency
so it seemed a little bit more formal
just to get into the door you know you
want to try to pull any kind of tricks
like that you can't not lying to people
or anything but just if you have a
friend with
kind of access like that or a friend who
works at an agency or someone who can do
you a favor and make at least an initial
call they don't need to say they're
reppin you but you know just always try
to find the ain't kinda back channels in
but then in addition to that try to get
in touch with the author you know try to
not directly I think try to do the
formal channels first you know that's
what she always wanted do you want to be
respectful first and if they put you in
touch
so like Davies agent put me in touch
with him and we got on the phone I told
him I wanted to make this into a film
and why I liked the story and and he
said yes and there was somebody
negotiated you know it was it was it was
relatively reasonable you know I'm you
can you can make things work with people
obviously what David and that this was
from a published work from you know it
wasn't a magazine article it was in a
very popular book it was it was a little
bit more it was way more complicated and
just by its sheer nature a little bit
more costly because you're setting
precedent and you're doing things like
that so it was it was difficult um in a
lot of ways even though everyone you
know David wanted me to do it and I want
to do it they're still agents and
they're still contracts and there's
still things that just naturally they're
always it's always complicated even when
everyone's amicable there's always a lot
because you're figuring things out and
this is you think about David and his
rights and it was really important to me
and I always advocated for this to is
like I just wanted this story I did you
know when he writes both people they
they write about their own life
experiences so you think about how
complicated those legal rights have to
be to make sure that you're not
optioning they of course can have to
give you the option to all of their life
you know it's only this one piece you
know and so it's it's you can just get
complicated depending on what the nature
of it is but I think it's about you know
being realistic knowing the rider who's
adopted them before adapted them before
but also being ambitious and I everyone
was telling me know about David everyone
was saying he doesn't say yes this is
too it's too big you don't have the
money but you know everyone's saying all
of those things I still went for it and
still worked out so I would never say
any of this to deter someone you know
but I'd also say that like hey if you
want to join if you want this John
Grisham book like know that John Grisham
has a history of you know selling his
rights for a lot of money and maybe
there's something really specific to do
for me there was something really
specific and particular about the story
that
I thought would fit David's Sensibility
so I felt that so I mean if you if it's
someone really famous but you feel
there's something really specific about
the way you're approaching the project I
say still go for it you know but
obviously if you like a courtroom
thriller from John Grisham it's you know
it's be realistic about it but also be
ambitious and even if that writer you
reach out to let's say it's like an
e-book or something they don't have any
representation you know make sure that
on their side too that they have lawyers
make sure everyone's happy and be
upfront and better to figure out if
there's gonna be conflicts before then
when you're you've already finished a
film and then suddenly someone has a
problem with it you know you want to get
that stuff out of the way right away but
you know a lot of writers will they'll
even sometimes give free options or
really cheap options for just like a
year and then you can update it later
you know there's a lot of ways to go
about getting access to material
you